welcome back to the edge with your boy
Michael Parsons live in your Bleacher
Report app we wrapped up an important
and a great year it went by so fast I
can't believe how fast it went we just
wrapped up the 2023 NFL regular
season and let's get right into it it's
playoff time everything's way more tense
way more serious not that things weren't
serious before but yall know
everything's on the line there is no
more next week there isn't no more
tomorrow there isn't no more we got to
get better it's winner go home and
everything matters every play every inch
every yard everything matters so let's
just talk about it wrap it up and just
know I enjoy my time with Y biggest
takeaway obviously we clench the NFC
East uh obviously that's a big one uh
becoming number two seed and being able
to play at home uh people know how well
we've been able to play at home so I
think that's very important for the
Dallas Cowboys um and very important to
obviously the energy everything changed
everyone's like oh we're home we get get
to play at home for at least two games
um obviously if we win on Sunday
hopefully we win you know how much is
important Green Bay Dallas doesn't get
any bigger but we're going to get into
that later the show but let's just wrap
it up got my 14th sack of the season um
big career high for me I said I wasn't
going to be a 13 guy no more just
speaking to existence I thought I was
going to be a 17 18 guy but we won't get
into that we all know we could have
should have would have but we had 14
this year obviously next year we're
trying to go bigger and better and just
keep taking raising the bar every year
raising the bar raising the bar raising
the bar but uh fifth players since 1982
with at least 40 career sacks in the
first three seasons uh super blessed
super honored and just thankful every
day the Dallas Cowboys chose me and they
put so much effort and energy into me
and obviously let's talk about the my
teammates CD this close to the Triple
Crown I mean hell of a Year Brother Don
Bland our interception leader led the
leag with nine interceptions true Ball
Hawk it's truly going to be amazing to
see and I'm so sick we didn't get to see
Bland and Trayvon together this year I
want oh my gosh it makes me so sad that
uh you know that one incident took that
away from us but I think Trayvon and
bland is going to be the best duo in the
NFL next year um I can't wait to see it
this is going to be so exciting I think
we have the two best ball Hawks in the
NFL and it's not even debatable
obviously Bland with career Hive nine
interceptions and Trayvon Diggs I think
he was 11 or 12 uh my rookie year but
truly amazing see uh one of the best
corners in the
NFL and then let's get into my
quarterback oh Dak Prescott called a
shot said he was going to have 10 picks
but not only did he not have 10 picks
but he led the league in touchdowns he's
my vote for MVP um he had a hell of a
year uh you know passing rating
completion percentage I mean mean Dak I
mean he just had a terrific gear could
be more proud of him and it was the
bounceback gear a lot of people he dealt
with the hand injury uh coming probably
rushed back earlier than he had to
Midway through the season last year just
trying to get in rid of them things uh
but he made no excuses he made no
excuses he just got better and I knew it
was going to be a special year for Dak
coming in the training camp I know y'all
saw the training camp uh when dak's
talking trash back everything's intense
between Trayvon and Dak and Dak just had
that Swagger man he had that he had that
composure he said I'm going keep getting
better I'm going keep going and man
number four hell of a year brother uh
you're a pro bowler you should be a all
proo no doubt in my mind uh I mean hell
of a year way to bounce back and like I
said he's going to get paid but
obviously in the NFC East this is a
ninth straight season that the NFC East
had a different uh had a repeat Champion
since the Eagles in 01 through 04 I mean
this is one of the most wied streaks
obviously uh there's a lot of Inc
consistencies in the NFC uh a lot of
great battles a lot of great teams
throughout this time period but I think
the Cowboys have a chance to go repeat
next year and break the streak um but it
it's been a hell of a run uh the Eagles
almost did a repeat uh so I think it's
the Cowboys turn next year to go do it
but it's going to be some great battles
y know Eagles Cowboys and I think
Washington will be better and the Giants
will be better it's going to be some
great battles uh super exciting but it
is one of the most wildest streaks there
has not been a repeat champion
but let's get across the league uh I saw
Shannon sharp go off on jamus Winston I
seen a lot of people talking about uh
jamus and all this stuff and I want to
talk about it you know it it's been it's
been kind of crazy I think in that
position you don't go for it um because
obviously the team's conceding you're in
Victory formation you're all the way
down the field but also from their their
side of it and I try to look at things
from both both sides
is if the whole team agreed to go for it
you know and it it wasn't just jamus and
everyone's like man let's just get him
in I mean it it's kind of hard to to
judge that it's not like jamus you know
made the call and no one agreed to do it
and he just uh let's just hear what
jamus had to say and then we'll we'll
just keep going off of that cuz I think
this is all extremely
important well I apologize to Da because
the play was was Victory but I also
explained to Da that it was a team
decision and uh and I think when you
have the A Team morale and I asked the
guys I said guys like what do what do
you want to do we know how much Jamal
means to this team and and I understood
from DA's perspective so I I I give him
that but da didn't condone that at all
you know he he didn't however uh we
decided as a team to do it and man we
got an interception to the one yard line
yeah you know like so if if if if we
would have scored would it still would
have been disrespectful right you know
so uh Tyron wasn't in on it was he no
Tyron was not not in it was it was it
was offensive team
discussion however when you when you
return the ball to the one yard line and
you have that opportunity we just had
that opportunity and uh and we decided
do you think it's the kind of thing
though that is forgotten fairly quickly
or you know what I mean I I think it
should be forgotten especially when the
scores are already
417 uh so I I don't know how how much
worse it can get uh but I got a ton of
respect for auor SM and the coach that
he is I think they do some incredible
things I didn't mean to I didn't want to
disrespect him that was not my intention
uh my intention was to lead the team
that I've been with the entire year and
we made a collective decision that we
wanted to get one of our guys who they
fight with blood sweing tears every game
in the end zone and uh I'm going feel
good about
that I think jamus has always been a
team guy I don't think any any amount of
jamus uh throughout any every we all
seen videos of Jam's speeches uh how he
handles himself he's always been a team
guy so I I I disagree how everyone's
been sham of him you know he it's not
like jamus wouldn't scored he thought of
scoring for his teammates he's always
thinking about others I always put in
that perspective who has that man been
before this incident and jamus always
been a team guy I mean you you got to
tip your hat to somebody like jamus
thinking about the guys in the room uh
especially morale boost you know
obviously you always want to score a
touchdown you always want to see your
impact throughout the year and Jamal
battled uh injuries and obviously having
Alva Kamar out there uh I think I think
you know in his eyes it was the wrong
call and he shouldn't feel wrong about
it because he's looking out for others
uh even though it's going to make
someone upset and and that's just part
of life not everything you do you do is
going to make everyone happy so at the
regardless uh James there's there's no
hate over here and you know uh and
everyone around him supported that
decision so there should be no shame um
about that and and that's Point Blank
period um and obviously the National
Championship uh extremely National
Championship very very exciting uh there
it's a LoveHate relationship obviously
between Michigan because I'm in a big 10
with Penn State and I'm always rocking
where we are but Michigan is national
championships uh national champions and
it is it is what it is I
mean you know and it sucks and I did
pick Washington and and that was on me
but obviously Michael pennix was hurt um
and what we all thought was Texas had a
lot of success at a run game over
Washington and we felt like that would
transfer over um to the national
championship and it did Blake Kum and
Edwards had uh terrific games two
touchdowns over 100 yards they were both
uh you know they're in a top four of
running backs with two touchdowns over
100 yards and it's both uh Michigan
running backs and it it carried over
there was no adjustments so it it stins
a little bit I was rooting for Michael
pennix without a doubt uh and and if you
watch the game Michael pennix was under
duress the whole game Michigan dominated
the line of scrimmage the whole game
that absolutely dominated the whole game
uh very sad uh it was a tough game it's
hard to win any game when you're getting
dominated up front and that's just point
blank period
um it
it ah congratulations Michigan but you
already know it's always uh we are and
then we also talked about the people
that was up in the suite we saw uh man
we saw Michael Jordan there Derek Jeter
obviously Michael Jordan's there because
he he's representing Jordan uh and you
saw Travis Scott I mean this is a this
is a hell of a sweep I mean there's so
much like Hall of Fame and greatness in
that sweet I wish I was in that sweet
bro the thing I I mean I'm dying to meet
Michael Jordan on just a mentality
perspective on how he came into every
week how he uh proved his greatness
every day I mean him and Kobe are like
one of my favorite athletes ever when it
comes to mentality uh grit and and even
Jeter I mean Jeter done so many great
things in New York and I mean just on
the terms of greatness when you striving
for greatness you just want to hear that
and I know they just piggyback off each
other all the time I mean that's a hell
of a sweet I mean if I could create a
sweet those people would be in my Suite
um man you are you who you hang with uh
Point Break period um and then there's a
lot of talk about Jim Harbaugh should
Jim Harbaugh leave and go to the NFL
honestly at this point it it's almost
the same thing especially with nil uh
the nil is making it so much more uh
money and businesslike but I think the
way Jim Harbaugh turned Michigan around
and after winning one Championship I
think it would be so hard to just walk
away I I I just don't think I could walk
away after winning One National
Championship obviously he got two big 10
championships now now obviously switched
the reain from Michigan uh from Ohio
State to Michigan and I think Penn
State's on his way but I I think he has
to do it again keep repeating I don't
think he just did all that to get one
championship and go uh I'm pretty sure
he got bigger dreams and aspirations uh
in the NFL and things like that but uh
the way he's turning around uh College I
it's I think it'll be too hard to leave
and I think he's having more fun I think
a lot of people and they said they have
a lot more fun impacting young kids'
lives and obviously the grown man part
of the business like the NFL um so I
think Jim might stay I I think uh Jim
might
stay uh and he and he will uh continue
to dominate in college football I don't
think he would leave but obviously it's
the end of the year and it's time to
wrap up the NFL awards and this is going
to be a good one obviously we going to
break it down thoughts opinions on who's
the most valuable defensive player the
Rookie of the Year and let's get into I
tweeted this out earlier let's get into
discussion what is the difference
between dominant and a good player and I
think we often tend to try to collide
them both and say a dominant player is
the same as a is a good player I'm going
be honest with you if you if you put
into let's just go to edges right you
put into perspective I think how someone
is blocked right I you no GM head coach
is going to leave me oneon-one with
anybody Trent Williams I said Trent I
you said you one of the best of tackles
why why is he coming him he's like bro
no one's leaving you oneon-one like no
one's leaving miles Garrett oneon-one no
one's leaving uh even watching Nick Bosa
uh I watch a lot of his film uh at least
70% of the time no one's leaving him
one1 even Max Crosby I think MX CR is
one of the best Edge rushers High motor
guys and he's not he's not even
consistent L 101 and then you see that's
why you look at stats like these like
man we can Bank on our guy beating him
uh you know oneon-one we just got to
make a bet and our quarterback got to
make the read and the ball come out
quick but bro a lot of these guys
getting left one-onone and that's just
reality I mean we could watch the tape
look at the tape and that's just edges
and you look at like receivers right if
you look at CD lamb nobody's leaving CD
by himself he's a dominant player in
this league he he is not a good wide
receiver I think a good wide receiver
anyone in the means of seven uh 7 to
1100 1300 plus you're an elite dominant
receiver and sometimes we try to collide
them and make comparisons in reality is
no comparison these people do not get
the same game plan they do not get the
same treatment sometimes I'm getting out
triple I'm getting chipped and I'm
getting a slide with the guard helping
like there is not the same as being a
dominant and a good player like uh
dominant this you tilt the field like
Julio Jones in his prime he used to tilt
the field Calvin Johnson they used to
tilt the field to put more coverage
pieces on and Bank on other people
beating them that's what dominance is I
feel like nowadays we we just we we're
exposed to mediocrity and now we're
we're coming away from what a dominant
player is and what he brings to the game
Tyreek Hill's dominant player bro back
toback 1700 yard seasons there is no
comparison he's the top three wide
receiver in this NFL like but we're not
going to put him in the same category as
other receivers it's just not the truth
or the reality about it but you know
let's get right into the awards um cuz
there is no confusion on this show uh
we're this is the real honest I don't
care about media Outlets whatever this
is the honest player opinion um of you
know and obviously the top three MVP are
Lamar Jackson de Prescott Brock pie I
think without and we could go through
the stats right uh Lamar Jackson 3600
yards uh 24 touchdowns seven
interceptions 821 yards rushing um great
year uh he's the lead for MVP um right
now but without a doubt it has to be Dak
Prescott 4,500 yards uh 36 touchdowns
lead the NFL has nine interceptions uh
less overall turnovers and uh you know
qbr 72.6 second qbr uh without a doubt I
think deck Prescott had the better year
um I mean look at the Ravens defense
They just won a Triple Crown um they had
the best defense in the NFL this year
without a doubt like there there H there
there's back and forth there's balance
to it right Lamar played great uh
obviously he's going to win MVP cuz how
the media looks at it but Dak played the
best football in the NFL I don't you
know what as a quarterback no one can
tell me differently the stats the film
uh the play he's been able to extend
what he did this year he he is by far my
MVP I mean and those who said it's not
about stats and uh they said it's not
about interceptions whatever when it
matter Dak won we lost some close games
we won some close games it's a game of
inches uh our defense could have played
better uh there was only maybe one or
two I mean everyone has a bad game Lamar
had bad games before obviously pry had
bad games like trying to say oh he had a
bad game here and this would cost him
that that's just ridiculous overall if
you look at year statistically and
performance Dak Prescott has been the
best uh
quarterback in the NFL I and obviously
pry had a great year he had 31
touchdowns 91 interceptions uh 4,200
yards and and I think he had a really
good year but D Dak is the MVP um Point
Blank period um and you know let's get
into coach of the year uh Browns head
coach uh Deo Ryan um and Shane ston for
the coachs uh my coach of the year would
would have to be the Browns I mean uh
demo Ryan if it was if Deshawn wats and
Nick chub didn't get hurt you might have
to give it to Deo Ryan and that's going
to get a it's going to get real tricky
when it comes off to offensive rookie of
the year because this is GNA make it
hard but the Browns I mean the way
they've been able to bounce back they're
in the playoffs without the quarterback
without the running back they're missing
Jack Collins jetri GIS they're missing
key pieces to the o line and the way
they just been battled back uh I mean
without a
doubt the Browns it it should be the
Browns I mean their defense play
phenomenal they've been outplaying
everyone uh man oh man it's kind of it's
been really special what they did but
the way demo Ryan went from number one
pick to playoffs and C J St I mean wow I
mean it it was honestly it's been it's
been exceptional um let's say assistant
coach of the year um
she I you know it it's tough cuz you
know I'm going against my guy Dan and I
think we played a hell of a year but
then again it might have to go to the
Browns DC I mean that defense only
allowed 270 yards uh they had 28 total
takeaways um and allowed you you know
just under 21 just about 21 points per
game uh I think the Browns overall coach
their coaching staff has been phenomenal
they've been amazing um I think they're
going to take this all the way out I
mean what they've been able to
accomplish this year has been truly
amazing I'm truly excited to see this
Browns texting matchup in the first
round uh this is going to be it's going
to be one for the
books comeback play the year uh this is
tough is between Demar Hamlin Joe flacko
and Josh dos I think if Josh dos was
able to
sustain of being a starter didn't lose
his job I think he would have won but as
of right now I would have to give it to
Joe Flaco I mean Joe flacko he's been
able to come into this league uh throw
for multiple 300 yard games and help
lead them the playoffs and win crucial
games uh you would give it to Demar
Hamlin but the fact that he only played
two games uh really ruins it in my eyes
but obviously his comeback is
unbelievable the fact that he's playing
his game he's he's doing what he needs
to do to uh stay healthy and it's always
great to see a brother who we almost
lost on the field but Joe flacko them
last four or five games has been truly
phenomenal uh playing like he is that
Super Bowl guy that he once was I mean
it it's truly special so I'mma have to
give it to Joe Flo he's going to be our
comeback play the year so that's three
that's three Browns that's already uh
here offensive player of the year um th
this is tough and and this is the hard
um it's between Chris mcaffrey Tyreek
Hill and uh CD lamb and it sucks because
I know if Tyreek Hill didn't battle that
ankle injury uh he would have broke the
record I it's tough you know finishing
just shot 1,00 yards and he has 13 TDS
uh it's truly phenomenal but you know it
the offensive play of the year is
probably going to be Christian mcaffrey
I don't think there's a player that
means more to his team than uh Christian
mcaffrey uh the way he's uh he's a off
he's a running threat and a wide
receiver threat 21 total touchdowns uh
over 2,000 total yards uh it's been uh
truly phenomenal to see uh Tyreek Hill
and CD obviously the two best receivers
in the league right now uh tord gears
but Christian mcaffrey he just played
lights out this year he will be our
offensive player of the year uh
defensive play the year uh I what I and
this is this is this is tough cuz
obviously uh I'm in it so people might
say I'm biased but honestly it has to
between be me and Miles uh I think me
and Miles has been some of the most if
not dominant people uh in a game of
football uh you know I'm not even going
to uh pick that one cuz we're going to
leave that up to the fans I need y'all
to comment who y'all think y defense
player the year is um because obviously
we don't want to be biased but I think
we've been the most dominant uh and
efficient rushers in the NFL and you
know it's not even close I mean you look
at all the statistics uh we both lead
him uh pressures tied for sacks uh he
had more Force fumbles but tackles all
around I think being miles has been uh
two of the best rushers in NFL without a
doubt and and and I and I don't even
second guess it uh offensive Rookie of
the Year um this is this is tough right
you got CJ Stout and uh puka and this is
why I'm struggling because I CJ he
missed he missed him three games because
of concussion and he still finished for
41 100 yards 23 touchdowns five
interceptions so imagine what his stats
could do it and he did it without Noah
brown tank Dale got injured um he missed
half his line the whole year so the
adversity he's battled and the fact that
he still made playoffs and what he's
been able to do with such an
interception rate has been truly
phenomenal he went from he was the
number two pick in the draft and
led uh this team to the playoffs like
this is truly phenomenal like man oh man
like and this is hard cuz puka he has he
has the most receptions and receiving
yards by a rookie in a single
season like I it's hard to give that up
and CJ's my dog like this is such a
tough decision but uh I I hate to go
CJ's had a great year and I think if
puka didn't have the year he's had it it
would go to CJ under any other
circumstances cuz you look
at you look at uh man you you just look
at NFL history I think it's so hard to
break history like history is so crucial
uh so important and it's such a hard
thing to do the 1486 and 105 receptions
like it's just so hard to do it and he
did it as a rookie I think he did enough
because he Jamar Chase and Jeffrey
jerson were offensive rookie of the
years and he beat both of them
statistically so it almost has to be him
um it it has to be history uh what he's
accomplished he did more than both of
them and they both won it it'll be
interesting how the voters see it but
it's probably going to go to puka even
though I think CJ should get it um man
this is a tough one but it has to it
probably has to be puka the year he's
had uh but CJ what a unbelievable year
like the fact that he was able to lead
that team the playoffs he was once an
MVP obviously the concussion and things
like that hurt but man oh man and then
Defensive Rookie of the Year it's
between Jaylen Carter uh six sacks two
Force fumbles Will Anderson uh 45
tackles seven sacks um I think it has to
go to Jaylen Carter I think Jaylen has
been super dominant
um you know it's been it's been un oh
and Devon Witherspoon in it too
obviously but you know Jaylen Carter has
just been a man amongst boys since the
moment he came into the league uh super
dominant well Anderson had a great year
great rookie year
but you know uh Jaylen Carter he's just
has been so dominant I knew he would
have this ceiling that would be
unmatchable uh unimaginable he is just a
great player um and I'm excited to see
what he does in the future I think he
has potentially be one of the best uh
you know defensive tackles in the league
if he's not top five
already um but that's our award winners
you know uh let's leave let's get right
in the playoffs uh you know let's look
at uh the matchups uh man on man would
this be good uh Tyreek Hills heading
back to Kansas City Kansas City up upset
the Miami Dolphins earlier in the Years
be it'll be really interesting to see
how they bounce
back um Matthew Safford back to Detroit
super great mat I feel like this is part
of the script like the NFL has been
working this for a long time because the
way Kansas City kind of melted towards
the end of the year the way uh the Rams
kind of peak towards the end of the year
um I think this is all part of the
script guys no doubt about it these
storytale endings obviously the Packers
is facing uh Dallas with and that's Mike
McCarthy the Dez catch this is all part
of the script no doubt in my mind how
they set this up so perfectly um man oh
man I think this is going to be one of
the best playoffs we've seen a long time
uh I don't see no weaknesses on either
side I think all these teams
is you know all these teams are just
very good matchups uh it it it's going
to be
it's going to be super interesting uh to
see how this how this goes uh this is a
first round like no other I mean so much
history in all these matchups stayers
bills I mean this is going to be super
great uh man oh man uh let's get into
some predictions though um obviously the
Ravens have a buy uh Browns at
Texans uh I think this is kind of where
the the ending ends for the Texans um
you know I think the Browns has been so
good
defensively I don't know if they'll and
they have Martin Emerson they got gr
delpit uh Ward uh and uh so many good
defensive
pieces um and obviously I think the
Texans line obiously better it's going
to be very interesting to tonso and
Garrett matchup
um but I think the Browns edges out um
they just have so much on that defense
that and I think CJ's very limited to
the weapons he has right now because of
the injuries it's going to be very
interesting to see it but if CJ's able
to pull this out I mean that would be
such a great win it's going to be such
an interesting matchup um but I have to
go with the Browns in week
one uh Dolphins at Chiefs I I can't lie
we don't know jayen
Waddles um we don't know Jaylen W's
Health yet so he may still be out uh
obviously losing Bradley chub Jaylen
Phillips they still got van gekle uh I
believe they just fac another injury uh
the Dolphins and it's like can they
bounce back can they fight through
theity and win this game in uh Kansas
City this would be a truly great matchup
um I'm I'm I'm super excited to see it
these injuries are just killing the
Dolphins though it it truly sucks but
and the Chiefs pull out another close
one I think the first time around the
Dolphins played a great defensive game
to the Chiefs and I think they could
have won that game I mean man oh man
this is going to be a good one but I'mma
have to go with the Chiefs well
honestly cuz honestly I might go with
the dolphins I I'm going continue to go
with the dolphins because the Chiefs
struggle offensively um they haven't
been playing their greatest ball um it
they haven't been
uh they haven't been at their at their
best we haven't seen them at their best
and I'm afraid those turnovers them
drops will cost them this game
especially when you have an explosive
offense like the Dolphins is going to be
very interesting to see and the Dolphins
just signed Justin Houston and Bruce
Irving so they're they're replacing
those rushers is going to be very
interesting to see uh it's going to be a
great match up but I may have to go with
the dolphins Steelers at bills bills won
last of five games in the AFC East after
starting six and six I think the bills
is trending in a right way I think the
Bills win this game obviously just
seeing TJ Watts out uh a a terrible loss
for the Steelers um without a doubt I
mean the this sucks I mean this has been
a terrible loss losing TJ watt obviously
defense player of the year candidate and
obviously you still got Alex heith and
great things that could still get
pressure but the way Josh Allen has been
playing is going to be a great game I
mean they're talking about high
temperatures with snow and the Steelers
have struggled to run the ball uh it's I
we're going to have to go to they're in
Josh's house it's going to have to go
bills we're going to go bills bills over
Steelers uh and the 49er and the NFC
49ers have to buy obviously we got
Eagles bucks uh I don't know too much
about the Eagles right now especially
with jaylen's finger is is uh Devonte
Smith playing is AJ Brown what's his
health uh they've been battling they
their safety Destro ACL uh obviously I
believe Darius slayback can they fight
through this the bugs have been trending
in the right way uh Baker M Baker
Mayfield has been playing good ball
their defense has been playing great
ball can eagles get through this
adversity and win at the Bucks it's
going to be super exciting to see
um who knows do they get their pieces
back can jayen uh find a way to fight
through the adversity with his hand and
win this playoff game who knows uh but
if they can't if those players are out
Jaylen can't play then obviously we have
to go Bucks we have to go Bucks but I
think the Eagles have more Talent they
can get through this adversity they do
what they have to do they can easily
beat the bucks um but if they can't the
injuries if they can't play then
obviously the Bucks are going to win
Rams at Lions uh I don't think it's
going to be very interesting to see uh
Kyon Williams been running lights out
the Rams have been able to run the ball
at extremely high level and obviously
what puka Cooper cup and Matthew
Stafford's been amazing he's returning
to Detroit there might be a little bit
of J between jarro G and Matthew
Stafford there might be a little spice
right there who
knows but this is going to be a great
game the Lions have the number one R run
defense they have Aidan Hutchinson um
they have some great rushers but it's
going to be the question can they get
stops against the Rams can they get
those crucial stops uh the Rams have
been super explosive with KY RS in the
lineup I'mma have to go Rams are going
to beat lions in in the first round of
playoffs and that leads us to Packers
Cowboys uh with Coach McCarthy coach
McCarthy are the deaded down the media
he said I'm not going to let y'all make
this about me this is about the guys
I've been praising Jordan love all
season he had one of the best debutes of
uh as a Packer quarterback and you know
Packer history uh obviously 41 over 4100
yards 32 touchdowns 11 interceptions and
yes I said Jordan is a friend of mine
but we are not friends on Sunday this is
going to be a great matchup um the
Packers are also the youngest team to
make playoffs since the NFL expanded to
16 games in 1978 this is a young team uh
it's going to be super super super dope
matchup super exciting I mean man oh man
and this is going to be a close one uh
this is going to be a good one at that
but we're at home ah man it's going to
be a great
game uh I can't wait uh obviously lafor
is one of the best coaches um and you
know Mike McCarthy's one of the best
coach it's gonna be it's gonna be a
heated match up on Sunday great game and
obviously they got ajent Aaron Jones
Aaron Dylan AJ Dylan I mean super great
matchup can't wait to play out there
Sunday and before we go to the chat
let's look at this hilarious video going
around of jaer getting mistaken for a
fan on a local
broadcast bring that energy right to
Texas I'm just here to tell you p is
back you heard it from a
fan that analyst has to be better that's
one of the best uh DBS in a game of
football I mean man oh man Jer is one of
the funniest dudes in the league there's
no doubt about it uh let's take some
final questions from the chat uh before
we end off the final episode of the
regular season it's been amazing to be
here with
y'all
um and from the chat Mike is dpoy lead
lead the league in pressures and now a
holding call against him in 11 game that
stat is crazy uh regardless hands to the
face Holdings it don't matter we just
got to be relentless we just got to keep
going keep being a hunter and just keep
being who we
are Dan Quinn is a lot of coaching
rumors are you doing anything to
convince DQ to stay uh absolutely not DQ
always got to do his best for him uh I
know how good our relationship are is uh
he would never do anything or hop on
anything without you know kind of
talking to me first or at least reaching
out to me uh you know I wish Dan the
best but I know for right now he's
focused on playoffs he's our DC and I
know he he's he's ready to do anything
to
win uh what is the NFL script say say
for you and the Cowboys and my script
that I sent to the NFL was that we're
winning the Super Bowl it don't matter
who we play uh the score is going to be
31-28 Dallas Cowboys uh and that was the
script that I was giving so if y'all
need some scor cards I just gave you one
how is the prep week in the playoffs
different than the regular season no
difference we're still off on a Tuesday
uh hit getting into it on Wednesday and
Thursday and obviously it's going to be
a relaxing weekend before we hit it
Sunday afternoon on a big day uh and
it's going to be super exciting but
Cowboy Nation y know what time it is
it's play
it's time to protect the Lions Den is
Winer go home I want to see y'all next
week and potentially the week after that
but who knows let's get it man regular
season's over it's been a hell of a year
it's been a pleasure speaking to y'all
being with y'all uh I couldn't be more
thankful for everyone who's tapped in
and been a part of this podcast and that
and it could be more than things so the
line is out appreciate y'all all love
peace
ah